a difficult week ahead for nicola
sturgeon that could see the first
minister fighting for her own
and scotland's political future
it may very well be that i didn't get
everything right that's for others to
judge
but in one of the most invidious
political and personal situations i have
ever faced
i believe i acted properly and
appropriately and the overall
i made the best judgments i could
she awaits the outcome of two inquiries
into her government's handling
of sexual assault allegations against
alex salmond
sturgeon's former boss mentor and friend
last week the leaked conclusions of a
cross-party parliamentary inquiry
suggested she'd given an
inaccurate account of her meetings with
salmond in 2018
to discuss the allegations but the
question upon which sturgeon's job may
depend
is whether she broke the ministerial
code either by misleading parliament
deliberately or by promising to
intervene on alex salmon's behalf
as he alleges she did which she denies
parliament will produce its report
already partially leaked
on tuesday but it's the independent
review by sturgeon's own
advisor on the ministerial code james
hamilton qc
that will pronounce on that central
question of whether she broke the code
if so scotland's first minister will
find herself under
intense pressure to resign scotland's
future
should be in scotland's hands that is
what this debate is about the future of
our country
nicolas sturgeon is determined that
scotland should hold another referendum
on independence
something prime minister boris johnson
has refused
the question was voted down in 2015 but
brexit has caused a rise in support for
independence
among remain-minded scots an anticipated
victory for nicola sturgeon's
scottish national party in parliamentary
elections this may would strengthen her
hand
but a crisis of trust at the heart of
the nationalist cause
could tear it all down jonah al jazeera
edinburgh